J'ai appris que les dieux de l'Olympe sont
réels et parfois ils ont des enfants
avec des humains appelés sang-mêlé, c'était à
peu près comme n'importe qui d'autre qui mange de la viande,
mais avec quelques différences notables,
la mythologie grecque nous a en fait suivis à
travers les âges, cela prend tout un
tas de mythes  et en les plaçant dans le
monde moderne, cela ouvre votre esprit à
votre imagination deux choses différentes
comme les centaures les satyres les cyclopes vous avez l'impression
que ça pourrait être malheureux de
marcher sur la terre aujourd'hui je pense que nous sommes
à l'
Olympe c'est une chose de l'Olympe nous '  re nous sommes à
Washington DC d'accord ah notre histoire vient
de la mythologie grecque la quête de l'
eau inexplorée et mortelle nous partons dans ce
voyage pour obtenir la toison d'or de la
couche de Polyphème rien n'est nécessairement
comme vous le pensez que ça va être j'en reçois euh
quatre  venti half-caf no-whip lattes et
euh coup supplémentaire de nectar de nectar que vous
n'avez pas eu vous avez un paquet de lapin vivant
désolé voyez vous avez les mains pleines le
monde est un monde vraiment intéressant je
pense que c'est très amusant j'adore l'idée de
mettre à jour à travers les grands mythes et
légendes Olympic Parcel Service excusez-moi
nous recherchons Hermès peu insulté
vous ne m'avez pas reconnu
Hermès est le dieu messager et nous le
rencontrons travaillant dans un magasin UPS le
le fonctionnement interne dont les proportions sont mythologiques
vérifiez-le une installation de traitement et d'emballage de tri à la pointe de la
technologie ne touchez pas au fait que c'est
comme un tout autre domaine de la réalité
que les gens ne voient pas c'est un char de
damnation qui ressemble à un Nouveau  York City taxi
même différence
que j'ai été à New York Jackie halète une nouvelle
fille c'est définitivement une tactique de l'enfer
ils ne savent pas les mensonges
il y a beaucoup de trucs amusants fous chute
Oh papa qui est comme à moitié proche de
revenir peux tu baiser
vous